one of the primary missions of the
Academy is to honor individuals who
played a pivotal role in developing
technology that has shaped the way we
experience movies and few people have
had as much impact on cinema sound as
David Winchester grey
today we take for granted that movies
will sound the same from dubbing stage
to dubbing stage from dubbing stage to
theater and from one exhibition chained
to another that was not always true
thanks to David it is now David began
his career building custom Oh building
custom electronics in the music world
for artists such as the kinks the
Mahavishnu Orchestra Steely Dan and
Frank Zappa he came to Dolby in 1980 and
began to introduce Dolby technology to
the film community one highlight of that
effort was the introduction of Dolby SR
ray Dolby's benchmark achievement in
analog sound processing which extended
the life of 35 millimeter magnetic
recorders and provided a pristine sound
with a completely silent background as
you went through generations of sound
mixing let's fast forward a few years to
nineteen ninety david was a member of
the format design team for what became
known as dolby digital but universally
called dolby SRD david tackled the
practical considerations of the format
from sound negative exposure to high
speed release printing his efforts
established the reliability of the
format leading directly to the universal
adoption of dolby digital by studios and
production companies there is a long
history of multi-channel formats in
cinema from fantasy and cinerama to
today's immersive formats such as Dolby
Atmos some have stood the test of time
and others have fallen by the wayside
fundamentally good ideas tend to
reappear in new technological guys an
example is the 70 millimeter stereo
surround format first proposed in 1978
for Superman and then adopted most
famously by Francis Ford Coppola for
apocalypse now although dozens of titles
followed over the next two decades most
of them shepherded through post
production by David the lasting impact
of the format was the influence that it
had on the introduction of multi-channel
digital sound for 35 millimeter film
bringing the roadshow 70 millimeter
experience to the neighborhood multiplex
in 1998 the Academy presented David with
the John a Bonner medal of commendation
for outstanding service and dedication
and upholding the high standards of the
academy of motion picture arts and
sciences he has always been instrumental
in updating the Academy state of the art
theatre capabilities including the
design and atmos implementation at the
Dolby Theatre in Hollywood which is now
home to the Oscars the award I'm about
to present is named after Gordon I
sawyer a three-time Oscar winner and
former head of the sound department at
Samuel Goldwyn Studios who served as a
member of the scientific and technical
awards committee from 1936 to 1977
right it is presented to an individual
whose technological contributions have
brought credit to the industry tonight I
could not be more pleased to present the
Gordon Sawyer award to David Winchester
grade
wow so Cheryl thank you so much I really
appreciate that okay so i think i would
like to start by thanking the saitek
committee and the board of governors and
i think i'm going to have to get my
speech out because i'm way more nervous
than i thought it would be but i am so
proud to not only receive the gordons
heuer award but to be in the same
company with the 24 previous recipients
three of those recipients are here
tonight that's Don Rogers Harry Deimos
and Peter Anderson
um
I'm in awe and I'm incredibly humbled
but well I'm probably preaching to the
choir I just like to start by saying
that the work done by the brilliant
people on the saitek awards committee
year after year is absolutely
astonishing I don't think people realize
how much work this committee does and
for all the surrogate reports that are
issued every year I just I just want to
say thank you to all of you for all that
work it's just it's amazing so
I'd also like to give my congratulations
especially to dr. Hornbeck and to all
the awardees this evening I've sat at
this dinner for some 35 years and
there's some really brilliant people
getting Awards it's just it's
spectacular I fully understand that it's
getting late and I fully understand that
I'm the last awardee tonight but I'm
going to tell you this is only going to
happen to me once and I'm going to take
full advantage so if you need to go to
the bathroom go now because you can be
so good for those of you who noticed
some of those early pictures when I had
hair and I was thin I lived in Vermont
in those days because when you make your
living on the road you can live anywhere
you damn well please so for those of you
who are familiar with New England and
vermont in particular you'll know that
there's a fifth season okay and for
those of you don't know it's called mud
season okay and the reason that it's
called mud season is because it's very
cold in that part of the country in the
winter and the frost goes two to three
feet deep and in the spring when things
warm up that thaws and you get quagmire
you just get absolute quagmire so I want
to tell you about 43 years ago I came
back into this little town in Vermont
from working on tour and I decided to go
visit a young lady who had recently
broken up with a very good friend of
mine there are a lot of dirt roads and
driveways in the state of Vermont um she
had both
okay and so she wasn't home when I
arrived and on my cape of trying to back
out of the driveway i buried my VW bus
up to the engine in mud and was not able
to get it free so completely stuck it's
a very very cold and dark night as well
so my only choice was to walk the three
or four miles back into town about a
half a mile into that walk a car
approaches which was this lady that I
had attempted to go see and she kindly
offers me to make some coffee and to
warm up and then she'll take me back
home I would like to say that at least
metaphorically I never went home again
this lady's name is Deborah she is
sitting right there and I can't thank
her enough
for the unbelievable support being my
confidant and listening to all my
bitching moaning and complaining over
the years thank you so much many years
later we had a son Travis and a number
of years after that we had a daughter
Shannon I am forever grateful for your
understanding that dad's a geek and is a
complete workaholic so but you guys made
working worth it so thank you I don't
think anybody accomplishes anything
without a lot of help and going around
and I am certainly no different I spent
all of the 70s on the road in rock and
roll we saw some of the bands and I
learned a lot on the road Steely Dan
taught me about the quality Lou Reed
taught me about you necessarily talent
isn't there but the presentation needs
to be really good I improved my
troubleshooting skills and signal flow
skills to no end and I didn't tour with
the kinks and for those of you who are
familiar with the kinks Ray Davies wrote
a song called celluloid heroes which has
always been one of my favorites but
there's a lyric in celluloid heroes that
says those who are successful be always
on your guard because success walks
hand-in-hand with failure along
hollywood boulevard and I've hopefully
played along with that the whole time
I'd also like to thank Frank Zappa I
spent three years there and Frank really
taught me to to try my ideas and and he
also always told me that there would be
failure but that's okay because you have
to keep
crying so I built for him basically a
little mini guitar synthesizer that
would sound like a French horn it was
horrible I gotta tell you all right you
know like trying to playing guitar and
make it sound like a French horn was
just so stupid as it turns out but when
I added about twenty percent distortion
to it it was absolutely magical so I'd
like to thank you and Alan from Dolby
Laboratories who had the damn good sense
to hire me in the first place and for
his introduction to the technical side
of this industry and Eoin see also the
other one who convinced me that I really
wanted to be involved with the standards
process and for those of you who are
involved in standards process you know
that it can be an unbelievably
frustrating experience but also like to
thank ray Dolby ray taught me the
benefit of humility for sure and he also
taught me to always ask questions but
more importantly he always convinced me
to really listen to the answers and I
wasn't very good at that when i first
started at dolby so now it's definitely
helped no doubt about it and I'm so
thankful every other Tuesday's I was
lucky enough to have lunch with ray and
the lunch special special at the corner
location was meatloaf and the discussion
often was technical and based around
engineering and for me it doesn't get
much better than meatloaf and
engineering so I also like to thank bill
Jasper who was the president and who's
here of Dolby for a for a long period of
time bill kept me at dolby when I
thought I wanted to go elsewhere and
convinced me that I didn't and I also
want to thank him for his faith in my
non engineering abilities to that in one
quick little story bill sent me to the
executive instance
for engineers at the Stanford Business
School and told me don't screw this up
okay so I just would like to say sixteen
years later that you have my public
apology for pranking the stanford
business school but i would like to
point out that even though that's the
case we got an award for that and my
team won the business simulation so
thing John Bonner the late John Boehner
for showing and teaching me the whys and
wherefores of the industry
technologically speaking he was a great
mentor he's also the one who sponsored
me and encouraged me to get involved
with the Academy Don Hall who is here
somewhere there is for teaching me how
editors work and why they work in the
way they work and he also gave me so
many history lessons and was also an
incredible supporter of the benefits
that I may be able to bring to this to
this to the sound community and then
there's Don Rogers for all of you I
think most of the people in this room
know don don taught me the politics of
this industry he taught me gave me so
many introductions to the post
production community and lots and lots
of advice probably more than I really
wanted but and for those of you who've
come to this event for a while I want to
thank gone again for being one hell of a
good sport for all the saitek evenings
where he was the fall guy you know and
my favorite one was dawn the human
puppet anybody remember that one yeah
cuz it was great I also like to thank
Doug Greenfield Doug and I have been
working together here in Los Angeles for
nearly 30 years until I met Doug I was
strictly a function guy I could care
less what the damn thing look like Doug
showed me or I would actually say how
need me to pay attention to form so Doug
also got me to think about other
possibilities
technically and politically he's been a
great sounding board and that pun is
fully intended so thank you Doug I'd
also like to say thank you for the
incredible support for me tonight from
my Dolby colleagues I think there's like
80 of you hear something I know it's a
terrific three tables worth and it's
headed up by our CEO Kevin Yemen and
David Dolby came as well which I really
appreciate all the support petrol Vlahos
in his acceptance speech many years ago
for the Gordon Sawyer awards that he
certainly hoped that this being a
Lifetime Achievement Award it didn't
mean he was finished achieving and that
he fully intended to continue to achieve
I fully agree and I'm hoping that my
next achievement is simply to finish
this speech I wish I could be as elegant
a little Quint as Jonathan Erlin
sentiments in his boner award speech but
my sentiment is simply a love for our
film industry and more specifically a
love of sound for motion pictures our
industry is such an incredibly unique
marriage of the Arts and Sciences and
pitta mised by events like this I am
amazed every day at that Union so for me
i doubt i will ever be more proud than I
am right now and I probably will never
be as excited than I am right now thank
you so very very much and good night
you
hey Mouse yes Margo what did the digital
artist say to the producer when asked to
simulate the destruction of the moon two
weeks before the movie's release what
would you look at that was bad out of
time so thank you we had a lot of fun
tonight so thanks for having us release
is a pleasure because you know okay
thank you and congratulations to all
tonight's honorees our storytellers we
thank you for making our films look
stunning and sound incredible good night
everyone and also also uh we want to
remind all the honorees to come up on
stage so we can take a picture with all
of you yeah good love that just a
personal thing it's just for us thank
you guys
you